9. sınıf tayfam, yine yeni, yeniden
diyoruz. Yepyeni bir alt başlık
atıyoruz. Üslü ifadeler tik attık o
tarafta bitirdik. Şimdi geldi 9. sınıf
Matbook serimizde köklü ifadelere. Sayfa
kaçları açıyoruz? 21 diye hatırlıyorum.
Hemen bir açalım bakalım beraber. Sen de
benimle birlikte elinde kalemin önünde
kitabını açtın sayfa 21'i. Köklü
ifadeyle başlayacağız. Tabii önce
tanımıyla başlayacağız. Ne diyorum?
Gönder, gönder gelsin hocam. Şimdi köklü
ifade dediğim olay nedir? Bunu anlatalım
sana. Değil mi? Matematikte bir nokta
var arkadaş. Tanım, tanım, tanım. Tanım
bilirsen gerçekten sen rahat
edebilirsin. Şimdi tanım ne diyor? N de
N 1'den büyük bir pozitif tam sayı,
tamam. Ve A bir gerçek sayı olmak üzere
A da bir gerçek sayı. N de 1'den büyük
bir pozitif tam sayı.
Eşitliğini sağlayan x üssü n eşittir A
ifadesinde bu eşitliği sağlayan x
sayısına aslında A'nın n'inci dereceden
kökü denir. Şimdi okuyunca en baştan
anlayamıyor olabilirsin. Neden biliyor
musun? Çünkü biz bugüne kadar hep
seninle şunu yaptık. Üslü ifadelerde 2
üssü 5 dedik cevap kaça eşittir mesela?
32'ye eşittir dedik. Ama gel gelelim
seninle şunu yapsaydık ne olurdu?
Cevabı 32 olan
hangi sayının 5. kuvvetidir?
Hangi sayının 5. kuvveti 32'dir ya da
cümlesini kurduğumda sen düşünüp ne
derdin bana? Bak az önce çözdüğüm o soru
2 üssü 5 ifadesi eşittir 32 ifadesini
tersten çözmeye çalışıyorum. Hangi
sayının 5. dereceden kuvveti 32'ye
eşittir? 2 hocam. Evet doğru. Ama
matematikçi bunu anlatırken şöyle
anlatıyor. Misal biz normalde bir
denklem çözeceğimiz zaman şöyle çözmüyor
muyuz seninle birlikte? Hocam x'i bulur
musun bana dediğinde bu denklemi
çözerken 1'i karşıya atıyorsun. Nasıl
geçer? Çıkarma olarak geçer. 4'ü karşıya
atıyorsun. Nasıl geçer? Bölme olarak
geçer. Cevap diyorsun eşittir 2. Tamam.
Çarpmayı bölme at, toplamayı çıkarma at.
E, işte
çıkarmayı toplama olarak at karşıya. Ama
ya üslü ifadeyi karşıya atmak
istiyorsun? Çünkü senin artık bilmediğin
değer bu. Hangi sayının 5. dereceden
kuvveti 32'dir? Hocam, bilinmeyeni
yalnız bırakırız. Ya matematikçiler de
demiş ki, üslü ifade karşıya geçerken
nasıl geçsin? Nasıl geçsin? Ya çarpmayı
bölme atıyordun işte. Hah, buna da
demişler köklü ifade yapalım. Buradaki
üst kökün derecesi olur. 5. dereceden
kök 32 şeklinde okunur. İşte köklü
ifadenin doğduğu an bu andır. Hani sen
bugüne kadar üslü ifade hesaplıyordun.
Adam demiş ki bugün, ya acaba hangi üslü
ifadenin şuuncu kuvveti şuyana eşittir?
İşte o ifadeyi tabanı bulmaya
çalışıyorsun köklü ifadede.
Yani x dediğimiz ifade
n'inci dereceden kök a şeklinde burada
okunacak. Burada n dediğim yer kökün
derecesi oluyor. Kaçıncı dereceden kök
olduğunu almış anlamış oluruz. Ve 2.
dereceden kök yazılmıyor bildiğin gibi.
3, 4, onlar yazılıyor. İçerisindeki a
ifadesine de kökün içine adını
vereceğiz. Şimdi gel bakalım. Köklü
ifadelerde gerçek sayı olma şartı. Her
köklü ifade bir gerçek sayı olmayabilir
arkadaş. Burada dikkat edeceğimiz bazı
noktalar var. Bazı bir tanım aralıkları
var. Her köklü ifade gerçek sayı
belirtmeyebilir. Gerçek sayı olma durumu
kökün derecesine göre belirlenir.
Örneğin, eğer ki n tek ise. N dediğim
ifade neydi? Kökün derecesiydi. Kökün
içindeki sayı canı ne isterse olur. Canı
ne isterse den kastım ne? Negatif olur,
pozitif olur, eksi olur, her şey
olabilir. Ama kökün derecesi neyse
tekse.
A istediği bütün değerleri alabilir. A
dediğim ifade de kökün içerisindeki o
ifadeydi. Tamam?
Geldim. Eğer n çiftse. Yani kökün
derecesi çiftse, kök içindeki sayı a ya
0'dır hocam, ya da 0'dan büyüktür. Asla
içerisi negatif olamaz. Ne zaman negatif
olamaz hocam? İşte kritik vaka. N çift
olduğunda içerisi ya sıfırdır ya da
sıfırdan büyüktür. Örneğin
16 kök içerisindeyse a pozitif hiçbir
sıkıntı yok. Dışarı zaten 4 diye de
çıkıyor, biliyorsun bunu. Hocam diyorsun
ki böyle bir gerçek sayı var mıdır?
Vardır. Ama kök içerisinde -16 diye bir
gerçek sayı yoktur. Sebep? Hocam bak
burada aslında 2 yazıyor. 2. dereceden
kök var. E bu 2 denen kökün derecesi
nasıl bir kök derecesidir? Çift
dereceden bir kök derecesi, çift
sayıdır. Haliyle çift olduğu için
içerisi asla ne olamaz? Negatif olamaz.
Ya bir dakika da hocam neden? Ya aslında
nedeni yine üslü sayıya dayanıyor. Sen
kalkıp 2'nin 4. dereceden kuvvetini
aldığında cevap 16 çıkıyor ya.
Ya hocam sen 4 tane ifadeyi yan yana
çarpıyorsun, çift dereceden bahsetmeye
çalışıyorum. Yan yana çarptığında
cevabın negatif çıkma şansı var mı? Yani
sen bu sorunun cevabına -16 diyebilir
misin? Mesela bunu sildim. Burada bir
kutucuk var. Hangi sayının 4. kuvveti
16'dır desem ne diyecektin? Hocam öyle
bir sayı yoktur. -16 diyemezsin 4.
kuvvete. Çünkü eksiler elbet
çarpıldığında çift adet varsa cevap
kesinlikle ne çıkmak zorunda? Pozitif
çıkmak zorunda. O zaman bunun bir çözümü
olabilir mi bu halde? Olamaz. Hepsinin
bir mantığı var. Ezbere değil bak hiçbir
şey.
Kimde? Soru 46. Bak köklü ifadelerin
cevaplarını bulmaya çalışmayacağız
seninle birlikte burada. Yapacağımız tek
şey bu bir gerçek sayı mıdır değil
midir? Çok basit düşün. Aşağıdaki köklü
ifadelerden gerçek sayı olanların yanına
tik atacağız. Gerçek sayı olmayanların
yanına da çarpı sembolü koyacağız. Bir
kere şuna karar verelim. İçerisi pozitif
mi negatif mi? Üslü sayı biliyorsun bak
düzenleyerek yaz. Hocam bu
2'nin karesi, daha doğrusu 4'ün karesi
sadece ona ait. Eksisine ait değil. Yani
işleme yaptığında cevap ne gelir? -√16
gelir. Haliyle aha bu bir köklü ifade
olamaz, gerçek sayı belirtemez. Niye? 2.
dereceden, çift dereceden kök var,
içerisi negatif. Olmaz arkadaş, öyle bir
durum yok. Hocam -3 üssü 4'ün 4.
dereceden kuvveti alındığında, karekök
alındığında ne yapacağız? Burada içerisi
aslında pozitif mi, negatif mi? Bana onu
söyle. Bu 4 kime ait? Bunun tamamına
ait. -3'ün 4. kuvveti kaça ait, kaça
eşittir? 81'e eşittir. İçerisi pozitif
mi? Pozitif. O zaman bu bir gerçek
sayıdır. Bak senden tek istediğim bu
cevapları yazmaya çalışmıyoruz. Kök 0.
Hocam kökün derecesi 2 ise içerisi 0 da
olur. Birçok öğrenci bunu karıştırır.
0'a eşit de olabilir, 0'dan büyük de
olabilir. Yani bu da bir gerçek sayıdır.
Hatta hatta bunun cevabı direkt 0'a da
eşittir. Hocam kökün derecesi tek. Hiç
içine bakma bile. Bu bir gerçek sayıdır.
Kökün derecesi tek. İçerisine ya beni
ilgilendirmez. Bu kesinlikle bir gerçek
sayıdır.
Kökün derecesi çift, içerisi negatif.
Kusura bakma bu bir gerçek sayı olamaz
diyeceksin. Geldim. 4, içerisi negatif.
Hocam bu bir gerçek sayı olamaz. Geldim.
Burası 3, hiç bakmadım bile. Onayladım
geçtim. Ne olursa olsun kabul diyorsun
çünkü o tarafta. Kökün derecesi nedir?
2'dir, çifttir. -1'in 3. dereceden
kuvvete aldığımda cevap ne gelir? Bak
şimdi yapalım bunu. İçerisi -1 kalır. E
içerisi kök içerisinde -1 negatiftir. E
2. dereceden kök vardır. Kusura bakma
böyle bir gerçek sayı tanımlayamazsın.
Hocam bunun cevabı nedir yani
dediğinizde olay şu bak. Böyle bir sayı
yok. Olmayan şeyin cevabını nasıl
bulayım de. Tamam?
Kök içerisinde -6'nın karesi. -6'nın
karesini aldığında cevap nereye götürür
seni? 36'ya götürür. Peki kök içerisinde
36'nın cevabı neye eşittir? 6 diye çıkar
falan da. Ya ben onunla ilgilenmiyorum.
Kökün derecesi burada 2, önü pozitif.
Ben bunu onaylarım geçerim hocam
diyeceksin. Anlaştık mı? Geldim.
Şimdi burası 4. dereceden. Orada 5.
dereceden kuvvet var, -2. Sen bu kuvveti
uyguladığında cevap içeride -32 gelir mi
4. dereceden kuvvette? Gelir. Tamam da
burası çiftken içerisi negatif olamaz.
Böyle bir sayı tanımlanamaz diyeceksin.
Yani bu bir gerçek sayı değildir. Aynı
şekilde burada 2 yazıyor, burada negatif
var. Hiç düşünmedim. Dedim ki, böyle bir
gerçek sayı tanımlamak mümkün değildir.
Şimdi,
iki tane soru tipi var. Özellikle hani
böyle
içerideki o kök tanımını, o kök
muhabbetini anlayıp anlamadığını
sorgulatacak. Yani mevzu şuraya gitti.
Burası çiftse, buranın kesinlikle büyük
eşit 0 olması lazım. Burası tekse, yani
kökün derecesi tekse, bu paşa gönlü ne
isterse olur. Yani istediği bütün gerçek
sayı değerlerini alabilir dedim. Tamam?
Şimdi, bu yukarıda bir tane toplama
işlemim var köklü ifadelerle toplamını
oluşturan. Her köklü ifade bir gerçek
sayı olduğuna göre, x'in alabileceği kaç
tane doğal sayı değeri vardır diyor.
Hocam, buradaki ifadenin bir köklü ifade
belirtebilmesi için, kökün derecesi çift
olduğu için, içerisinin 0'dan büyük ya
da eşit olması gerekir. Yani senin
yazman gereken kural burada budur.
Şimdi yan tarafa geçtim. Kökün derecesi
ne hocam? Çift. O zaman içerisi ne olmak
zorunda? 0'a eşit veya 0'dan büyük
olması gerekiyor.
Aldım, x'i karşıya attım. Aldım, -2'yi
karşıya attım. İkisini birleştirdim. x
dedim ortaya yazılsa, x denen değer
2'den büyük eşittir ama 7'den küçük
eşittir. Kaç tane x doğal sayı değeri
vardır diyor. x'in alabileceği doğal
sayı değerlerini yazalım mı? 2, 3, 4, 5,
6 ve 7 değerini alabilir. Yani 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6 tane.
Cevap 6 tane değer alır dedim. Noktayı
koydum, geldim sıradakine.
Bu soruda önce senin uğraşmanı
istiyorum. Hani hep dedim ya, bu ders
aslında bir özel ders konseptinde. Şimdi
kalemi eline almanı, bu soruya gerçekten
kendin düşünüp kendin çözmeni istiyorum.
Denedik mi?
İfadesi bir gerçek sayı olduğuna göre,
yani 3x - 12 ifadesi bir gerçek sayıysa
kökün derecesine baktım 2 çifttir,
içerisi büyük eşit 0'dır. Kısaca 3x
büyük eşittir 12'den x büyük eşittir her
tarafı 3'e böldüm 4'ten. Aynı şekilde
geldim kökün derecesi çift olduğu için 8
- x büyük eşit 0 olmalıdır. Kısaca 8
büyük eşittir x'ten. E aldım bu
arkadaşları bir araya getirdin. x büyük
eşitmiş 4'ten hocam ama küçük eşitmiş
8'den dedim. x'in alabileceği tam sayı
değerlerinin toplamını arıyorum. 4 var,
5 var, 6 var, 7 var, bir de 8 var
alabileceğimiz değerlerde. Şimdi bak
Eagle's metodu en dıştakileri topla 12.
En dıştakileri topla 12 yaptı mı 24? 6
daha toplam ne yapar? 30 yapar. Doğru
cevap 30'dur.
k ve x bir gerçek sayı olmak üzere k'nin
değerini soruyor. Şimdi k dediğim değer
burada.
Tamam da hocam biz x'i bilmiyoruz. Tamam
işte x'i bulacaksın, yerine yazacaksın.
Böylelikle k değerini bulacaksın. Peki
x'i nasıl bulacağım? İşte orada köklü
ifadenin tanımından faydalanacaksın.
Misal burası kaç hocam? 6. Burası kaç?
8. Bunlar çift dereceden kökler. Çift
dereceden köklerde kökün içerisi
kesinlikle ne olmak zorundaydı hocam?
0'dan büyük eşit olmak zorunda. Yani x -
5 büyük eşit 0'dır. Aynı şekilde 5 - x o
da büyük eşit 0'dır. Burada bir terslik
var gibi değil mi? -5'i al at karşıya. 5
x denen sayı 5'ten büyük eşit. x'i al at
karşıya. 5 denen sayı x'ten büyük eşit.
E hocam ben bunları birleştiremiyorum.
Yani x büyük eşit 5 ve x küçük eşit 5'se
mantıklı mı bu? Aslında mantıklı. Çünkü
x'in alabileceği tek bir değer var. Seni
kıstırıyor bak. Aralık bırakmıyor sana.
Sana tek bir tane tam sayı hakkı
veriyor. O da kaç? 5. Demek ki x değeri
kesinlikle 5. O halde x yerine 5 koyarak
geliyorum. 5 - 5 + 8. dereceden kök 5 -
5 + 3 x 5 - 1. Bir kere bu taraf
sıfırlandı değil mi? Kökün içi sıfır.
Burası da sıfırlandı. Artık k değerine
geldik. 3 x 5 15, 1'i gitti kaç kaldı?
14 geldi. Demek ki k'nin değeri
14 olmalıymış dedim.
Geldik 50. sorumuza üslü ifadelerden bu
yana. Bir kırtasiyenin vitrininde ön
yüzleri kare olan 3 not panosu kenarları
şekildeki gibi çakışacak biçimde
asılmış. Panoların alanları birim kare
cinsinden yazılmış. Buna göre şekilde
gösterilen x uzunluğu kaç birimdir?
Aradığım uzunluk şuradaki aralık yer.
Şimdi hocam bu köklü ifadeyle ne alakası
var? Aslında köklü ifadenin tanımıyla
alakalı. Misal, bu 144 sayısını sen elde
edebilmek için aslında ne dedin? Dedin
ki hocam diyelim ki bunun bir kenar
uzunluğu a olsun.
A'nın karesi ki karenin alanı böyle
bulunur, 144'e eşitmiş. Hangi sayının
karesi 144'tür? Aslında buradan a'nın
değerinin kaç olduğunu anladın? Köklü
ifadenin doğduğu yer. Hani bunu köklü
biçimde yazsam nasıl yazarım? Kök
içerisinde 144 yazarım.
Anlamı nedir? Hangi sayının karesi
144'tür? Hocam 12'nin. Bitti. Geldim.
Bir kenarına diğerinin bu sefer b
diyelim istersen. Şuradaki bir kenara b
dedim. B'nin karesi kaça eşitmiş? 25'e
eşitmiş. Hangi sayının karesi 25'e
eşittir? +5 de -5. İkisi de sağlar hem
+5
Ya sen bir uzunluktan bahsediyorsun.
Haliyle pozitif değeri almak zorundasın.
B'nin cevabı 5'tir. Geldim şuraya. c² =
441'e
eşitmiş. E o zaman c'nin değeri ne
olacaktır?
20'nin karesi 400'dür. Haliyle 21'in
karesi 441'dir. O halde c'nin değeri ne
olmalıdır dedim? 21 olmalıdır dedim.
Şimdi tüm bu değerleri yerlerine
yazalım. Hocam şuradan şurası 21 birim.
Şuradan şurası az önce bulduk 5 birim.
Şuradan şurası, onu da siyahla
gösterelim hadi, şuradan şurası da 12
birim. Haliyle şuranın toplamı 12 5 daha
ne yapar? 17 yapar. E sonuç, 17 ile x'in
toplamı 21 olmak zorunda. 17 + x =
21'se, x'in alabileceği değer kaç
birimdir? 4 birimdir dedim, vurdum
cevaba. 21. sayfa biter. 21. sayfaya
tikleri attık. Gönder gelsin sıradaki
ders. Aa pardon, sayfa dedim.
Şimdi, dedim ya, köklü ifadelerde adım
adım, yavaş yavaş, yavaş yavaş, küçük
adımlarla ama bütün köklü ifadeleri
eksiksiz öğrenecek şekilde ilerliyoruz.
Üslü ve köklü ifadelerin birbirleri
türünden yazılması. Aslında bizim köklü
ifadede çıkış noktamız neydi? Üslü
ifadeden geliyorduk, değil mi? 2 üssü 5
= 32. Aa, buraya kutu yazmışlar. 2 üssü
5 yok artık, kutu üssü 5 = 32. E
bilinmeyeni yalnız bırakıyorduk hocam.
Bilinmeyeni yalnız bırakmak demek ne
demek? Bu ifadeyi karşıya atmak demek. E
hocam, matematikçiler düşünmüş düşünmüş,
neye karar vermiş? Üslü ifadeyi karşıya
kökün derecesi olarak atalım demişler.
Attıklarında da elde ettiği cevap bu
oldu. Doğru mu? Böyle doğmuştu. E bir
dakika. Hocam, demek ki ben kökün
derecesini
üslü ifade olarak yazabiliyorum. Doğru
mu? Yani bir sayıda üslü olarak
yazılabiliyor gibi düşüneceğiz. O zaman
gel. Köklü ifadeler rasyonel üs
kullanılarak üslü ifade biçiminde
yazılabilir. Şimdi bir şey söyleyeceğim
burada.
Köklü ifadede hata yapıyorsan,
anlamadığın bir nokta varsa, sorun köklü
ifade değil. Çok net söyleyeyim sana.
Sorun üslü ifade.
Üslü ifade bilinmiyorsa, köklüde
zorlanır. Çünkü köklü ifadeyle
çözemediğin bütün soruları
üslü ifadeyle çözebilirsin. Çünkü her
köklü ifade aynı zamanda bir üslü
ifadedir. Niye? Gel göstereyim. Köklü
gösterim. Bana n. dereceden kök x üssü m
ifadesini verdiler. Ben bunu üslü
biçimde yazarken x'in üstündeki m aynen
kalır. Ama bu kök içeriye girerken yani
üst olarak yazılırken bölüm durumunda
yazılır.
x üssü m bölü n
Benim köklü ifademin üslü ifadeye
dönüşmüş hali budur. Şimdi bunun o zaman
tersi de mümkün hocam. Her köklü her
üslü ifade olmasa da bazı üslü ifadeler
köklü ifade tanımını sağlaması
gerekiyor. Birinci şart o. Sağlayan
ifadeler üslü ifadeden köklü ifadeye
dönüşebilir. Nasıl mı? Şu üstteki değer
paydadaki kısım x'in gerçek üssüdür.
Yazdım. Paydadaki kısım kökün
derecesidir. Onu da kökün derecesine
yazdık.
Anlaştık mı? Güzel.
Köklü ifadede zorlandığımız her soruda
eğer yardımcı olacaksa üslü ifadeye
çevirmek mantıklı. Misal, verilen
ifadeleri önce üslüyse köklü, köklüyse
üslüye çevireceğiz. Hocam, üstünde 1
var. Demek ki 3 üssü 1 yazacağım.
Paydada 3 var. Demek ki kökün derecesi 3
olacak. Geldim. Kökün derecesi 3'se
demek ki bu yazılırken nasıl yazılacak?
7 üssü 1 bölü 3 şeklinde yazılacak.
Geldim. Kökün üstünde, daha doğrusu üslü
ifadenin üstteki ifadesi ne olacaktır?
Bu sayının üstüne yazılacaktır.
Paydadaki kısım nereye yazılacak? Kökün
derecesine yazılacak. Peki 2 üssü 3
dediğim sayı kaça eşit? 8'e. Kökün
derecesi kaça eşit? 5'e.
Geldim buraya. Bak, 5 üssü 2 bölü 7.
5'in üstünde kaç var? 2 var. Kökün
derecesi kaç hocam? 7. Harikasın. E
kökün derecesi 7, 5'in karesi 25, 7'nci
dereceden kök 25. Aa, bir yandakini
unuttuk. Hocam, bak burada kaç var? 4
var. Hayır, 4 yazma. Gel 2'nin karesi
yazalım. 4 dediğim sayı 2'nin karesine
eşitti. 5'inci dereceden de kök var.
2'nin karesindeki 2 dursun. Bu kökün
derecesine yazarken nasıl yazıyordum
hocam? Bölüm şeklinde yazıyordum.
Harikasın.
Geldim buna. 36 dediğim sayı aslında
nedir? 6'nın karesidir. Kökün derecesi
kaç? 3. Yazarken nasıl yazacağım? 6 üssü
2 bölü 3. Her köklü ifade bir üslü
ifadedir. Yaz bunu yorumlara.
Unutmuyoruz bunu. Hocam, 7 üssü 4 bölü
3. 7 üssü 4 aynen kalıyor ama kökün
derecesi 3 burada oluyor. Geldim 81. 81
dediğim sayı 3 üssü 4 değil midir? Önce
onu yazıyorum. 3 üssü 4'ün kökün
derecesine 7 yazdım. 3 üssü 4'ü aynı
yerde bırakıyorum ve buradaki kökün
derecesini altına bölüm olarak
ekliyorum. Bu da güzel. Devam ettim. 13
üzeri -2 sıkıntı olur mu hocam? Hiçbir
sıkıntı yok. O zaten bir kuvvettir. 13
üssü -2 olarak kalsın. Paydadaki 5'i
kökün derecesine yazdım. 5. Hatta bunu
bir tur daha düzenlersem şöyle değil
midir? 13'ün karesi 169'dur ama üzeri -2
dediği için takla attırdım. Şöyle bir
köklü ifade elde ettim.
125 5'in 3. kuvvetidir. Kökün derecesi
orada 4. O halde yazarken 5 üssü 3 bölü
4 şeklinde yazmam gerekiyordu.
Her köklü ifade üslü, üslü ifadelerin
bazıları da köklü ifade olabilir. Neden
bazıları diyorsun Mehmet hocam? Çünkü
neyleri tutması gerekiyordu? Köklü
sayının tanımı tutması gerekiyordu.
Tutmazsa o tanım yazamıyorsun her şeyi
üslü ifadeyi.
Eylül hazırladı. Eylül hazırladığı bir
eşleştirme oyununda mor karttaki köklü
ifadeyi iki farklı üslü gösterimle
eşleştirmiş. A, B, C pozitif tam sayılar
olup kesirler sade haldedir. Buna göre A
çarpı C artı B işleminin sonucu nedir?
Şimdi bak, benden düzenleme istiyor.
Kök kartı. 4. dereceden kök 512. Bir
kere 512 2'nin kaçıncı kuvvetiydi? Gel
bir ona bakalım. 2 üzeri 6 nedir?
64'tür. 2 üzeri 7 nedir? 128'dir. 2
üzeri 8 nedir? 256'dır. 2 üzeri 9 nedir?
512'dir.
Aslında bu kök kartında yazan sayı kaç?
5 üssü
9 bölü kökün derecesini nasıl
yazıyordum? Bölüm olarak yazıyordum. 5
üssü 9/4. Peki geldim burada. 2 üssü
pardon 5 üssü diyorum ya. 2 üssü olacak.
Bu 5 üssü nereden geldi? Onu düzeltelim.
Şuradan ne de olsa 2'nin 9. kuvveti.
Burası 2 üssü AB. E hocam bunlar
birbirine eşmiş. Kısaca 2 üssü A/B
ifadesi 2 üssü 9/4 ifadesine eşit değil
mi? Eşit. E tabanlar eşit üssler de
birbirine eşit. Kısaca A/B ifadesi 9/4'e
eşit ve en sade hallerindelerse demek ki
A 9'a, B de 4'e eşitmiş. Onları gittim
kenarda yazdım. A'nın değeri 9'dur.
B'nin değeri 4'tür hocam. Şimdi geldim
sıkıntılı yere. Üssü kart 8 üssü A C/B.
8 üssü C/B ifadesinde 8 dediğim sayı 2
üssü 3 diye yazılır. Üssün üstünde C/B
ifadesi kalır mı? Kalır. Üssün üssü
çarpıldığı için üssü ifadelerden
geliyor. 2 üssü 3 C/B yazılır mı? Peki
bu ifade aslında en başta yazdığımız 2
üssü 9/4'e eş miymiş? Eşmiş hocam.
Onların birbirine eşit olduğunu
biliyoruz. Yani tabanlar eşitse üsslerde
birbirine eşittir. Kısaca 3 C/B
= 9/4. En sade hallerinde dediği için
herkes direkt karşısındakine eşit. B'nin
zaten 4 olduğunu bulmuştum. 3 C'nin
cevabı 9'sa C'nin cevabı 3'tür. Tabii
soru benden şunu istiyor.
A çarpı C. A'yı 9, C'yi 3 bulduk. B'yi
de kaç bulduk? 4 bulduk. 3 kere 9 27, 4
daha doğru cevabım ne gelecektir? 31
gelecektir. Haydi bakalım soru no 52
biter. Geldik kök dışına çıkarmaya.
Artık kök dışına çıkmaya başlıyoruz
yavaştan. Ufak ufak kök dışına çıkmaya
başlıyoruz.
A bir gerçek sayı ve N de 1'den büyük
bir tam sayı olmak üzere kök derecesi
ile kök içerisindeki üssün eşit olduğu
durumlarda biz kök dışına
çıkartabiliyoruz. Aslında genel mantık
nereden geliyor hocam? Şimdi diyorsun ki
sen 2 üssü 5, şurada kökün derecesi 5,
bunlar gitti cevap dışarı 2 diye çıkar.
Neden? Çünkü her üslü ifade ya da her
köklü ifade çevrilebiliyordu değil mi? 2
üssü, bunu üste yazıyorum, bunu bölüm
durumunda yazıyorum. Aslında yine üslü
ifadeden geliyor sonuç. Aa, cevap 2'ymiş
diyoruz. Anlaştık mı? Demek ki üsle kök
birbirine eşitse dışarı çıkabiliyorsun.
Ama gel gelelim.
Burada da sıkıntı var. Şöyle bir sıkıntı
var. Eğer n tekse, yani kökün derecesi
tek bir sayıysa, hiç sıkıntı yok. Direkt
dışarı çıkar hocam. Cevap direkt a'dır.
Bitti.
Ama
n çiftse, yani kökün derecesi 2, 4, 6, 8
gibi değerlerse, evet bunlar birbirini
götürdü, ama dışarı çıkarken nasıl
çıkarmak zorundayım? Mutlakayla çıkarmak
zorundayız. Başka şansımız yok.
Mutlakayla çıkacak abi.
Neden mutlakayla çıkıyorum hocam? Mesela
bak, 4. dereceden kök -3 üssü 4,
aşağıdaki örneğin aynısı. Aslında bu
sayı şöyle mi yazılır? -3 üssü 4/4,
değil mi? Sıkıntı yok. Aa, evet hocam
böyle. Tamam da bunlar sadeleşti, -3
üssü 1 kaldı, cevap -3
diyemezsin. Neden diyemem hocam? E
arkadaşım, şuradaki sayı -3'ün 4.
kuvveti aslında
oradaki eksi kaybolmaz mı 4. kuvvette?
Pozitife dönmez mi? Döner. 81 olur mu?
Olur. 81 dediğim sayı aslında kaça
eşittir? 3 üssü 4'e eşittir. Aslında
burada -3 üssü 4 yazmıyor. Aslında orada
3 üssü 4 yazıyor mantıken. Haliyle orada
3 üssü 4 yazıyorsa, e 3 üssü 4 de dışarı
şu 4'ler sadeleşir, dışarı çıkar, direkt
3 olarak çıkmaz mı? Çıkar. Çift olma
şansı burada kalmadığı için, bölüm
durumunda çiftlik teklik durumu
değişebildiği için, biz en baştaki
duruma göre düşünmek zorunda olduğumuz
için, bu cevap yanlış, bu cevap
doğrudur.
Buraya dikkat edeceksin, tamam mı? Kökün
derecesi çift sayı hocam, hep sıkıntı
var değil mi? Evet. Her
ifadeyi yazamıyorduk içerisine. Sıfıra
eşit ya da sıfırdan büyük olması
gerekiyordu. Kökün dışına da keza dışarı
çıkarırken yine içerinin negatif
olmaması gerekiyor, pozitif olması
gerekiyor. Ona dikkat ediyorsun.
Yani mutlak değerini alıyorsun. Hocam
bak bu ifade sadeleşti, direkt -2 olarak
çıktı. Hocam bu ifade sadeleşti ama
dışarı mutlak -8 çıktı, onun da cevabı
8. Veyahut bu soruyu şöyle çözersin.
Dersin ki hocam, bak bu köklü ifade
aslında -8'in karesi kaçtır? Kök
içerisinde 64'tür. Eksim eksi gitti. Kök
64 dediğim sayı kaçtır? 8'in karesidir.
8'in karesi, şurada da 2 var, bu 2'ler
gitti, cevap ne olarak gelir? 8. Hani
mutlakla falan uğraşmadığında bu. Tabii
ki mutlakla yapacağız, çok daha kısa
oluyor. Hocam çift dereceden kök var, o
zaman -3 dışarı mutlakla çıkacaktır.
Cevabı ne olacaktır? +3 olacaktır. 3 tek
dereceden köktür, hiç
olarak kalır. Tek dereceden köktür, hiç
ellemem, -5 olarak kalır zaten dışarı da
çıkar.
8 dışarı çıkarken mutlakla çıkacaktır.
Cevabı ne olacaktır? +2 olacaktır. 6
çift dereceden dışarı çıkarken mutlakla
çıkacaktır. Cevabı 4 olacaktır. 9 tek
dereceden, beni ilgilendirmez, cevabım
ne olmalıdır? -3 olmalıdır dedim,
noktayı koydum burada.
Aşağıdaki işlemlerin sonuçlarını
bulacağız şimdi.
Baktık burada da ne var? -2'nin 3.
dereceden kuvveti, bir de kökün derecesi
3. Hocam bunlar gider,
dışarı direkt -2 gelir. Neden? Tek
dereceli kuvvetlerde buna dikkat
etmiyorduk. Aradaki işlem artı. Çift
dereceden kök sadeleşti, dışarıda nasıl
çıkar? Mutlak değerce çıkar. Yani -2 +3,
cevap neye eşit?
1'e eşit.
6 sadeleşti, dışarı nasıl çıkar? Mutlak
değerce -4'le çıkar. Aradaki işlem ne
hocam? Eksi.
Beşler birbirini götürdü. Dışarı nasıl
çıkacak? Aynen çıkacak değil mi? Ama
önünde eksi olduğu için ben parantezle
çıkardım. Mutlakla değil bak, parantezle
çıkardım. Çünkü tek kuvvetti. -4
mutlağın dışına +4 çıktı. Eksiler
birbirini götürdü, +5 oldu. 4 5 daha
doğru cevabım kaçtır dedim? 9'dur dedim.
Karesi kökü götürdü. -7 dışarıya nasıl
çıktı? Mutlak değerle çıktı. 7 7'yi
götürdü. Dışarı nasıl çıktı? -1 olarak
çıktı. Onu da parantez içinde çıkardım.
Çünkü önünde toplama işlemi var. 8
sadeleşti. Önünde eksi var. Dışarıya
mutlak değerle çıktı. Dikkat, geliyor
soru. -7 mutlağın dışına +7 çıkar. Artı
eksi dışarı nasıl çıkar? -1 çıkar. Hocam
bak bu mutlaklıya dışarı 2 diye çıktı.
Önünde eksi var, -2 oldu. -1 -2 -3 oldu.
7'den 3 çıktı, 4 kaldı. Dikkat dikkat,
devam. Dokuzlar birbirini götürdü mü
hocam? Götürdü. Dışarı nasıl çıktı?
Aynen çıktı -3. Çünkü tek kuvvetti. Çift
kuvvet gitti. Dışarı nasıl çıktı? Dur.
Önünde eksiyi koydum. Şimdi mutlağı
koydum. Mutlak içerisinde -1 yazdım.
Hocam bu dışarı -3 diye çıktı. Önünde
eksi vardı, eksiyi koydum. Bu dışarı +1
çıktı. Önünde eksi bir eksi var zaten. O
zaman -1 gibi okundu.
-3 -1 daha cevabım ne yaptı? -4 çıktı.
Aman aman aman dikkat, işlem hatasına
açık. Dörtler gitti. Mutlak içerisinde
-6 olarak çıktık.
Üçler gitti. Ama önünde eksi var. Eksiyi
koydum. Dışarıya aynen çıktım. Hiç
mutlağa falan ihtiyacım yok. Sadece
önüne parantezimi ekledim. Beşler gitti.
Dışarı aynen çıkarım hocam. Hiç mutlağa
falan ihtiyacım yok. Çünkü tek kuvvet.
Geldim -6 mutlağın dışına 6 olarak
geldi. Eksi eksi gitti, +4 oldu. Artı
eksi -2 oldu. 6 4 daha 10. İkisi gitti.
Cevap 8'dir dedik.
Geldim 55. soruma.
Hocam şunlar gider mi? Gider. Dışarıya
nasıl çıkar? Mutlak içerisinde -8. 49
dediğim sayı 7'nin karesi midir? 7'nin
karesi ile bu sadeleşir. Dışarıya
önündeki eksiden dolayı -7 diye geldi.
-64 aslında -4 üssü 3 müdür?
Şu 3 şunu götürür. Bu dışarı artı ama
önündeki eksiden dolayı böyle -4 gibi
gelir mi? Gelir. Bu sayı 2 üssü 4'tür.
Hocam, kuvvetler birbirine eşit.
Sadeleşti. Önünde artı olduğu için +2
diye çıktı.
Mutlak içerisinde olduğu için 8. -7
şuradan -4 +2. 8 2 daha 10. Şuradan ne
geldi? -11 geldi. Cevabımız sadece
yalnız -1'dir dedim, noktayı koydum. 22.
sayfayı bitirdim. Şimdi bak burada bir
ara verelim. Bundan sonraki derste
tekrardan kaldığımız yerden yolumuza
devam edeceğiz. Çok da güzel soruları
yine birlikte çözüyor olacağız. Evet,
Matbook serimizde kaldığımız yerden bir
sonraki derste görüşmek üzere güzel
arkadaşım. Yorumlarda görüşelim. Videoyu
beğen mediysen beğenmeyi unutma.
rehbermatematik.com sitemize gelmediysen
mutlaka gel. Kitabın tamamını hem oradan
görebilirsin henüz almadıysan. Aynı
zamanda kütüphane bölümümüz, ders
programı bölümümüz, kamplar bölümümüz
hepsi orada.